all right it's finally done it took a
while we got there 40 all the way to
number one well done chris sims take
three weeks off take three weeks and one
day off on me sounds good i'm sold okay
fine see ya all right
wait the work's not over yet oh so i'm
filling the blanks as it relates to your
countdown there are blank quarterbacks
who could be
number one
next year how many could be number one
next year
i i think when i really look at that i
probably i'm gonna go with four four
names that i think jump out to me to
where i could say and i'm not including
patrick mahomes right i'm not including
but i look at
russell wilson desean watson
lamar jackson
right any of those three
and then
maybe another guy i'll throw into the
mix there
and i don't expect it but i think he's
on my is kyler murray i i'm
intrigued by cutler murray you know i
don't expect him to be up there at
number one but i think he's got the type
of talent
and
rare ability to where he could be a guy
here that challenges mahomes for like
the most exciting best quarterback in
football as we go on here so i think
those are the names that jump out to me
more than any any other ones that jump
out to you or you disagree with there
i'm just stunned i'm stunned i'm shocked
i'm appalled and i will be contacting
aaron rodgers not only did you take him
out of the number once but you now say
he has no chance of claiming it back
i i don't know if he does it if he does
hey listen you know i'll be here singing
oh aaron rodgers and throwing
everybody's face next year i i guess
what i'm just saying is i don't envision
at this point of his career him getting
like better like remarkably where i
think there's some other guys like hey
emma holmes and wilson can still get a
little bit better we know desean watson
and lamar and those guys there's just
room to grow they're going in different
directions and at different points of
their career it hurts me man stop doing
that it hurts my heart
as to the number one guy next year would
you take patrick mahomes or the field to
be number one
oh patrick mahomes no doubt about it you
know yes i i i i will be shocked if
we're doing this next year and patrick
mahomes wouldn't be my number one
quarterback i i really i think you know
we didn't even get to like i said
there's no weaknesses in his game and
you heard andy reid in that last segment
you know there's room to grow he's a
sponge he's going to continue to get
better i think there's still plays that
he leaves on the field uh a few times in
a given game you know we usually don't
have to really like pay attention to it
because he makes other plays to make up
for it but when i talk about real
efficiency and like taking advantage of
every little thing that's there to be
had i think at times mahomes maybe
leaves a few plays on the field every
now and then because he's trying not to
be too over aggressive or careless or
stupid that way and i think he'll
continue to you know what do i want to
say make that nuance of his game even
better and better
my general approach to this type of a
proposition is to always take the field
always take the field but you're not
here
no but but here's the thing
let's be realistic about what we're
looking at
we're looking at
a season of unprecedented uncertainty
we're looking at
the possibility that patrick mahomes is
going to be knocked out for three weeks
with the coronavirus where lamar jackson
may not be kyle murray may not be
and look at what it did to patrick
mahomes in the
chase for the regular season mvp the
knee injury that knocked him out for a
couple of weeks it opened the door for
lamar jackson so i just think with that
many great quarterbacks out there who
aren't named patrick mahomes i got to
take the field here even though i don't
feel strongly about it there's just too
many all the names you mentioned
one little slip up by patrick mahomes
one an outbreak on the chiefs that
doesn't involve him there's just too
much uncertainty to put all the eggs in
one basket i'd rather put the eggs in
the much broader basket given the
dynamics of this year
yeah the year does change things i mean
i hear you i i get it i'm actually
surprised to hear you take the field i
am you know i mean really
you know i mean you know
like realistically because you've
already said in the last segment that
this is the best quarterback you've ever
seen through two years of their career
and your 50 years of watching football
and paying attention
you know
like
do you expect him to be okay if things
are normal not the cobin 19 do you think
he's if everything's if yes okay
everything's normal he plays like he's
right here
not clear enough this run goes for it
well here's the thing were we
anticipating patrick mahomes in 2016 no
so i don't know who else is out there
who could blossom into a competitor to
patrick mahomes but based upon what i've
seen over the last 50 years
i don't see anyone
being like patrick mahomes anytime soon
so i think this is a mantle he is going
to hold indefinitely until one of those
kids that has completely revamped his
playing style after watching patrick
mahomes shows up in the nfl when patrick
mahomes is the guy you know with a
little gray in the beard little gray in
the hair maybe a little rickety slowing
down a little bit and then comes a guy
22-23 who plays just like he used to
that's when i think the torch gets
passed
yeah i think that's probably fair i mean
that's kind of the way i expect it you
know yes from what we've seen
you know there's just again there's no
weakness to the guy there's nothing
there's really nothing you can look at
and go oh
you know that's a little troubling if
that gets out of hand it can really mess
him up or whatever you know there's no
weakness to him and then there's really
not a glaring weakness to the supporting
cast around them and i think that's
what's scary too and that's when you
start to go whoa can they build a
dynasty and like you said can they you
know win multiple super bowls and start
to do that harder easier said than done
i know that but you know it's set up for
them to make that type of run especially
at least be one of those like offensive
greatest show on turf type teams for a
long time
when you give one of the greatest
coaches of the past 25 years the
greatest quarterback of all time
potentially
you're going to set the table not for
necessarily a dynasty but the chiefs are
going to be hanging around and hanging
around and hanging around they're going
to be on the porch kicking on the door
every year and they're going to kick the
door in
probably more often than most teams will
over the next 15 or 20 years all right
next topic
and we're gonna have to take a look at
the 21 to 40 graphic of the chris sims
top 40 quarterback countdown because
this question is the quarterback outside
the top 20 that could be top five next
year is who and the example is lamar
jackson went from 30 last year up into
the top five this year who in that group
of 20 chris from 21 to 40 has the chance
to get to the top five
yeah well i think
there's
really here's the the group that jumps
out to me 21 22
25
and maybe even 26 okay and that's baker
mayfield daniel jones drew lock and joe
burrow
i think those four guys to me
have potential to be that and i think
specifically when i look at him more
than anything like hey listen drew lock
is certainly a guy i think that has that
type of potential and of course has the
support system around them and baker
mayfield and daniel jones listen i'm not
you know giving up on baker mayfield by
any stretch of the imagination i'm not
i'm still a believer in him and there's
support there to go along with it too so
the more i talk about it the more i
think it's maybe a drew lock or a baker
mayfield would be the two names that
jump out to me more than any
boy if it's locked people are going to
be stunned they really are but
they shouldn't be because we saw enough
of him late last year to see what he can
be i'd go mayfield though i'd hedge
mayfield on this one because we saw him
play at a very high level in 2018 when
he had the right coaching and when we
broke down his placement at 21 we saw a
lot of bad mechanics a lot of bad habits
that manifested themselves in games and
even though they don't have the luxury
of working directly together face to
face i think kevin stefanski who has
worked with a bunch of different
quarterbacks over the years he was in
minnesota from 2006 through 2019
i think he'll be in a position to get
the most out of baker mayfield so of
those guys i think mayfield is the most
likely or just none of none of them make
it to the top five because you know what
the top five is pretty good i don't know
who in the top five has given up his
spot for one of these guys between 21
and 40 chris
no you're right well you know the top
five was like the easiest thing for me
this year you know and it usually isn't
because you usually have got you know oh
three through six or three through eight
so tough and it's nitpicky and all that
you know i went into this exercise this
year going i know who my top five is and
i know who number one is i just need to
figure out the exact order and where i
feel comfortable and that's when i go
back and watch tape and compare and
write some notes and things like that
but i'm with you i think it's going to
be very hard to break into the top five
uh with that group in there right now i
mean the only one that you look at and
go yeah you know is not still on the
rise upward is aaron rodgers and i don't
think he's going to have the type of
fall off that's going to be too drastic
in fact i wouldn't be shocked if he's
has a better year this this upcoming
year because of all the events of the
off season and everything like that than
he did last year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports